hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly video game chacho
every tuesday at two p.m. pacific right
here on video games com gamespot com or
if you're listening to this on a podcast
whenever the goddamn hell you want
although if you are at least in this on
a podcast you're missing out on myself
in Peters beautiful matching t-shirt
look at this together oh it doesn't look
at all they do this filter where they
make everything I where you look green
why my green cuz you're Irish it's st.
Patrick's Day pretty soon that's pretty
happy about that mark 17 yeah I'm going
to honor this friday that's why I her
home yeah you're making me host the show
next I know you're gonna have to host
the show they're gonna revolt no one's
gonna listen do your best Irish accent
my best Irish accent oh that's pretty
good that's very good what are you mehar
d do you want my I rejection I don't
have an Irish accent oh no you don't
know it's not all not got it all yeah
I'm sure it'll be fine I'm sure you'll
do a wonderful job it'll be good yeah
we've got a bunch of news on this week's
show though did you know twilight
princess finally out yes it is I thought
it came at ten years ago but apparently
it's at today at garden warfare 2 Far
Cry primal don't have season passes I
want to chat to you about that see if
there's any so a new trend that's
happening probably not but we can wish
at gears of war you guys got to play it
too earlier today on PC ultimate edition
for the first time yeah gonna check in
on that I'm Far Cry primal to see how
they're running on PC and then also you
and Mary went to see dark souls 3 yeah
last week yep uh uh bunch of stuff hit
the side today yeah lot of stuff
Australia office saw a lot of stuff to
down under yep yeah that's like jocks
house yeah you do not sticking you know
sir an accent no where's the car where's
the car I don't know where the guy he's
a Boston Malik where's the car that's we
left the car right here where's the car
there's a car can I do in Austria ladies
drop bears a wicked that that works it's
real good I don't know you you know as
well as I do well they go folks expect
this and much more entertainment of this
ilk over the next hour right here on
twitch.tv for sauce gamespot and of
course on gay.com first of all day
gentlemen a few weeks ago we celebrated
the wonderful 30th anniversary of Zelda
which made us all feel very old it's
been 10 years since its auto princess
came out and it's out again with new HD
visuals rob crossley review to first he
gave it a nine and ten he did I know I
like point2 better than one of us when
it came in 10 years ago that was an
infamous review back then was it not why
did Jeff did it well it was around the
same time as the whole you know gaming
winch oh really was it was writer in
that time that's why you really got axed
because I didn't give it that point two
extra if needed and Mike so you didn't
review a Rob reviewed it out of the UK
video reviews up on the website now but
you have them playing us yeah last
definitely and what's your take on it
what's what's it feel like uh they're
definitely some things don't hold up as
well as I I mean I always thought those
first two hours were a slog right not as
much so they do take a couple of those
chores out that you're doing on the
ranch and whatnot you still have to hold
up hoard all those Gert yeah you can do
heard all those goats heard early Gertz
yeah okay that's annoying but I'm and
it's still I like it a lot but there are
some spots in between the dungeons that
I don't remember being as kind of
clawing as they are now there's just as
much they used to be but in hindsight I
don't remember as much how does it
control because this was a game came out
on this was the one that was like Game
Cube on we yeah we and then game view
right weekly so they did have an on
motion control version but what does it
feel like playing that game like 10
years later does it does it does it feel
like a good because there's so much
stuff in that game would like archery
and like horse riding like does it feel
that like it works Taylor's a little bit
janky it feels better than like what I
remember I remember I was kind of forced
myself to liking to like most motion
controls yeah we and then um the
gamecube felt fine the camera i kind of
member being a little wonky if you
weren't using z targeting i think it was
kind of hard to get link to go straight
but the motion with a gamepad the actual
motion controls those actually work
really well just like they do with the
3ds games now and I like those that's
nice town I have to use like the thumb
stick to aim every time you want to use
the slingshot or the bow smashing yeah
we got a bunch of questions into twitch
keep them coming in folks I do at down
your dwyer on the twitch chat there if
you want to make sure I see it I got a
couple of other little questions though
about it i guess like this
I don't I don't even know how your
review a game like this when it comes
out again because it's like okay do we
like I feel like we have this
conversation if a couple of weeks now
but this is so many of these remakes but
like how do you judge a game based on
like how it plays taking the style do
you take nostalgia out of the equation
completely can you do that he'd better
have but then like heady like
mechanically it's obviously ten years in
the past and doesn't have like this it
doesn't work as well Rob did a good job
of explaining how some of the things
that seem outdated in the old Zelda game
you know it's because they may be are
oversimplified but the way that they
exist within the game is justified by
the things they open up and the things
they allow to happen hmm I'm trying i
think of a specific example but but yeah
like it it might be a little bit dated
but it also has dated in a way that it
offers experiences that we don't
normally see anymore because we've kind
of graduated from that type of game
design yeah um but yeah no I don't think
Rob really was influenced by a nostalgia
too much like he seemed to make a pretty
strong argument for why he thinks this
game makes sense right now and why it's
such a great experience it was really
divisive when it came out I remember I
wasn't so I didn't grab nitwit Nintendo
consoles and this was I think this might
have been the first Zelda played was was
winwaker but this was the first i think
i bought on launch day and to me it was
like okay i get this i wasn't too much
into like the wolf aspect of it no one
really is i don't ya do you think that
it still fondly remembered gang because
people i remember around that time we're
really looking for a realistic look wise
elder game and then they got it but then
a lot of them didn't really seem to dig
in the end its divisive I mean I know
kind of like might describe the opening
a few hours are kind of crap for some
people and the same thing was said about
Skyward Sword and it caused a lot of
people to write the game off entirely
yeah but uh yeah i don't i don't know
like it people also do like it yeah
because it's dark right i mean it's a
side of the zelda universe that we don't
get to see very often Majora's Mask is
the only other game in the series I can
really think of that kind of delves into
sinister themes as it were yeah so I
think people really do appreciate it for
that reason alone in some cases has sun
and the chat says people finally
remembered for its dungeons that's also
something that a
Rob brought up in their view jus dive
into a bunch of those they still feel as
fresh as they did back in two thousand
six yeah I like them more than I
remember I think I kind of had that
experience of taking you know the
rose-colored glasses off yeah after
playing last week there are a few things
that I don't like as much as I used to
but the dungeons definitely not only how
well they're designed in terms of the
puzzles themselves inside the dungeons
but I think twilight princess was the
first game in the series i played were
they really contextualize the dungeon so
it's not just this random temple that
you know the the sage is built to or
that was built to house a sage and you
know it's not this like out of context
thing it's it's just mansion up on it on
a mountain where the Yeti lives it's a
it's a mine where the go-arounds live
it's uh it's like a actual tree on the
edge of the forest where all these young
monkeys are hanging out it they did a
really good job man yeah they're like
believable locations all those the butts
are still pretty sure they get me yeah
oh that very detailed butts good how
does it look actually how does it sound
as well they both are very good I you
had mentioned how it's kind of it's a
much darker game overall and I think
they the soundtrack itself the score
really really I don't know if they've
changed it too much it just it sounds
great and it kind of emphasized that I
think the older I've gotten the more I
don't love the art style as much anymore
but i love the overall tone of the game
I think maybe when i was younger i just
am i expecting more of like a winwaker
kind of whimsical thing yeah and I I
like this a lot more that I've kind of
grown up with the series smashing there
you go did you hear that somebody found
a there's like a painting a framed
painting in one part of the game and
inside that painting was one of the
concept art for the new Wii U game oh
really yeah they stuck that in there Wow
solander was that just fan today I think
it was yeah it was like just on gas
today right it was funny is someone else
in that thread put up a photoshopped
image with that Assassin's Creed concept
art from the attorney for sure because
they reminded me that's pretty good yeah
yeah I wonder if there's a bunch more
whenever for the next couple of weeks
people gonna start like data mining the
game for any clues on good luck are we
gonna see that news out of this year we
better kind of have to hurry I yeah we
really do I mean I don't think the game
is not gonna sell if it gets pushed back
but I
nintendo needs good will and that would
be putting the game out this here and
you also saw the justin a walled the bad
one put up a great interviewed phil
spencer earlier today on gamespot and he
was talking about how he believes the NX
will be shown off at e3 this year and is
not pretty much set on it that's that
this stage is that like a confident III
is in set in stone but it seems pretty
concrete that it'll be around that time
whether they do it through a nintendo
director something like that yeah i mean
III isn't it's kind of a weird place to
announce a console these days it seems
to be better suited to games well
someone one of the most console
successful consoles in the world was an
acid III and released the next day so
maybe saturday buddy referring to a sega
saturn and ya know retailers didn't even
know that thing was going to be
available so like that I don't know III
think Nintendo has done a good job of
distinguishing what they do and what III
is over the past few years and I think
they're gonna maintain their
relationship and it'll probably be that
we hear about the console beforehand
right and then we see more extensive
demos of games at e3 with hands-on time
yeah that's kind of the way to do that
now I guess yeah yeah it's gonna be a
weird III but that on the EA doing their
own thing and the pc gaming show who's
coming back for better or for worse
remember that i remember the
presentation that was weird it was weird
yeah i was like it was like our show
like his stage show is just lasted for
[ __ ] for hours I know commendable
effort but yeah maybe it'll be better
second yeah yeah anyway we shall see at
the electronic triple-a but yeah if
you're interested in twilight princess
let us know in the comments below and
what are the dog what's up Andy were you
doing over there Sandy's last show by
the way so he's probably gonna decide
doing some good nonsense honest who was
Albert was up I don't want to leave I
don't believe either so yeah pull out
all your tricks today Batman alright
make it look real where yeah there you
go look I'm taking over camera work
that's got some gifts out of the show
not really hitting good work oh yeah let
us know what you think in the comments
below uh gentlemen this sort of struck
me this morning I want to have a quick
little chinwag which you guys banish I
use that term you only get so every time
only one Mike's on cuz i had a comment
about it at some point and it never
fails yeah it's the visual inside my
head and just gave it life it's another
reason why the podcast version is
is slightly lacking and thank you so
much by the way to everyone who's been
subscribing and reviewing us we really
appreciate it but yes as I was saying I
was thinking I was watching the one of
the latest episodes of the genkwa zishan
and Jim starting was talking about how
plants vs zombies garden warfare 2 is
oddly unique in that it doesn't have a
season pass right which is unique
considering its a game put out by yay
right and then also sort of thinking in
Far Cry primal which is an ubisoft game
and they tend to also have done season
pass or launch DLC or something and
that's also a game that has launched
with none of that and then we think it
was like earlier this week or late last
week one of the developers on the
division for Ubisoft was getting out
there and saying there won't be any
micro transactions on launch and you
know there won't be any pay-to-win stuff
at all in any stage and people are sort
of getting out ahead of this in a way
that they weren't last year when like we
had the evolved problem where this was a
game that was coming out which had 12
different well did not talk to me only
out like three or four different ways to
buy it which if you actually put the
time in wasn't that complicated but it
totally scrambled people because I felt
like oh god I'm gonna buy a sixty-dollar
game and then suddenly I'm not gonna
have like the best version I'm gonna
have this like right truncated version
yeah so do you think like I know it's
like it's only two pieces of data and it
doesn't represent like an overall trend
or anything but do you think that maybe
games companies now are being a little
bit more hesitant when it comes to being
so upfront about their season passes I
think they're willing to experiment now
I think they're finding that there's a
certain amount of the audience that
doesn't really like that idea and
doesn't latch on to it the other side of
that though is the fact that you look at
something like pvz2 and Far Cry primal
they're sort of built on the back of
existing games mmm and they might not
need that extra financial bump that
comes from a season pass and so it's a
good opportunity to experiment with not
offering it that might help them
incentivize it the division on the other
hand that's very different yeah because
that's a whole new property that seems
to be pretty complicated and taking a
long time to make so the fact that
they're not trying to get more money
back through season passes an extra TLC
and microtransactions does seem a bit
odd to me it almost seems
counterintuitive that you're right like
when it comes to they tend not to do it
for these these are two is fragile
which I've been like relatively
established and people know what they
are but then you'd also think that if
you want to sell DLC you'd only do them
in a franchise in which is like a fan
base rec Assassin's Creed is a good
example of like oh I love Assassin's
Creed I'm gonna buy the game and I get
the season pass because I'll be all in
like for instance for ladders one for me
we're like I haven't bought the season
pass actually I've just I wish I had now
because it's just gone up by 20 bucks
this morning right damn it yeah and [ __ ]
yeah but uh yeah like that those are
situations in which yeah of course i'll
buy cuz i'm like i'm a fan of this
series i have never purchased two
seasons IV no no never I I to me the
idea of throwing down money for things
that you are totally blind to like they
might say oh we have X number of
expansions and and this type of you know
additions like characters or stages
coming or whatever but you really don't
know what you're getting into I mean if
all that one's a perfect example because
they put the price up because they're
like oh it's actually gonna be more yeah
but it still shows that they didn't when
they were putting a price doc I did oh
yeah they had no clue yeah it seems like
such a shady business move to me I don't
think it's evil but I just think it
confuses everybody in terms of like how
we think about these games like is it at
what it is that launcher is it what it
is six months after a while yeah so I
don't know because it's never really
clear to me like what I'm getting if i
invest in that I just don't it's weird i
wonder if it if it's so particular game
to game as well because there are some
games where it's like you I can't like
fallout I'm like oh yes I guess season
pass stuff makes sense because it's this
large open world and you can plug
stories into it whereas when I think
about a game for whatever reason when I
think about a game like Assassin's Creed
I think know to me that's a game that
wraps itself up it is a story which is
sort of contained right so so anything
you add on to that is just sort of like
a different experience at that point
thanks superfluous or it's been take it
out which which is like the worst
possible thing what do you think my yeah
I don't know it seems like it's very
much a case-by-case basis cuz you have
like rocket League which would make
sense to keep adding incrementally to it
because no it's like these small you
know aesthetic things that you can pay
two bucks for every once in a while it's
like I've bought every single one of
those yeah I don't buy this stuff
usually yeah but if you had paid but if
they had set up front you want to do a
thirty-dollar season pass for the next
three years it the season pass
inherently becomes a gamble especially
when the developers like you had
mentioned
they themselves don't know sometimes mmm
um you know a lot of developers now I
mean not that this is the case with a
for access but I remember Jake Salomon
saying that they did not start working
on the DLC until XCOM 2 was finished
right so and that's another case where
they don't know what's going to be
coming out and I don't believe there was
a season pass for that but I mean
obviously there's paid DLC down the road
I think it's just I think it's worth
waiting to see what you're getting into
because you know like you pay for the
season pass you're locked in and uh I
don't know it does always raise
suspicions with me I don't know that all
developers are inherently doing it to
just kind of get money up front but i
guess that like inherently that's what's
for so I don't know I've always been
kind of suspicious about it yeah I can
return a game I don't like or at least
traded back in for credit what I do the
season pass that's full of stuff that I
just don't care about yeah especially in
the digital domain it's way harder to
make those cult-like those calls right
up front I was asking just in the better
cuz i really love to know like how they
sell like we've no visibility on how
these season passes do you have to
imagine some of them do pretty well like
i imagine call of duties for instance
like they built a leech off of that
obviously that's not around anymore but
and i was trying to look a lot like you
know steam spire something to see if you
could like figure out what the sales
were of them but there's none there you
can't see it i just i'd love to know cuz
to me it's like who is buying these like
even when i worked in retail people
didn't really pre-order that often like
we put all this effort into making sure
those pre order stuff all over the shops
but like people didn't really pre-order
yeah that they kind of knew they pre
order for the ones we're like oh you're
gonna have a problem than gta4 because
there's just gonna it's gonna be sold
out but like other ones these days does
that even happen do you sell out I mean
like digital now anyway so right right
exactly so you have that option hmm but
yeah like special editions are the only
things worth pre-ordering a think yeah
it's really weird I feel like like for
instance fire emblem was like that's a
really good case for a pre-order like
game because already making a couple of
yeah it's all in 15 minutes yeah that
edition I'd love to know the wood to see
the word thing is is then when we like
talk to people you know in the comments
are on the chatter whatever it's almost
unanimously people who do not like DLC
season biases so like is this are ya
just wondering like is this trend
against it or reaction to that reality
or if we are only viewing this very
small piece of the pie and actually
there are millions of people
pre-ordering in buying season pass
that's a problem
we face being in the games press anyway
we subject like this weird hyper focus
on like our little world we try to
understand the broader view but it's
difficult and I think publishers
probably have that same problem
understanding their audience completely
yeah that I guess extrapolate a little
bit I guess it would I hope it does
become a trend i hope that developers
and publishers have realized there's
enough of a stigma attached to the deals
like this that maybe it actually becomes
harmful to have ice in the long run like
that's what I was wondering with is like
the same thing in any business is if
you're going after money it usually
takes a couple years before people
realize that this is a bad idea usually
take somebody losing their job and a new
person coming and going let's not do
this [ __ ] anymore to stop for them to
stop doing it so I wonder if this is a
lot of yeah companies being like finally
like actually this is causing more harm
than good it's ruining the relationship
with our community that's you know an
investment that's really important maybe
we should stop doing it I mean Ubisoft
definitely have to had that reaction
with you know pulling back an assassin's
creed a little bit and like not being so
crazy about their DLC plans in future so
like when I yay oh sorry like when I see
something about a season pass I
immediately see a publisher who's
desperate hmmm which may or may not be
true but that's sort of my immediate
takeaway is like oh they they're not
gonna make enough on the game that
they've released and they need to sort
of like you know stuff the coffers with
ya put this money that they'll put
forward to put into something down the
road but right now it's like crap we got
to be some more money back um I'm rig
grin Jean pan I'm gonna go with I think
publishers don't care have any pre order
or by DLC for them the numbers don't
matter because it's fun actually
benefits the many out like that's a good
point it's like any money earned this
money you know especially if it's
additional content on top of your your
base game like I wonder how hard it is
for them to like extrapolate how much it
costs to make the DLC considering so
much of the work for the dlc was already
done again it's probably case by case
but or even like subsequent games
whether the sequels or other properties
you know talking to a ton of developers
they always say if you're a bigger
company I remember when I used to talk
to like Looking Glass Studios I said
every game they made was just the most
like 70-something percent of the money
was going towards something else they
were going to make or making it's just
this I don't know if that's still a case
because this was a few years ago but
like a cascading structure that kind of
just keeps feeding back into itself yeah
trickle-down effect yeah hmm there you
go ah all right let us know what you
think let us know with your anecdotal
evidence do you buy season passes did
you buy season passes in the past and
then stop buying them now maybe I wonder
if that's a trend the people of that
yeah the fallout dlc for instance is
that one that you've jumped in on let us
know in the comments below gentlemen we
have two things to talk about in
relation to pc games which may or may
not be running properly Far Cry primal
came out today we'll talk about that in
a little bit first of all though Gears
of War so the ultimate edition came out
on pc today yes yes and to specify
Windows 10 yeah ok it's only I don't
windows that which means DirectX 12
right is it only available via the
windows 10 store or is the budget that
is our box copy do we know there's not
as now okay so you had some problems
with it this morning but also the end
this morning but it may have been
rectified what's what's going on so yeah
yesterday on two separate rigs the one
at the office we have what the 980
Titans triple SLI GTX 980 TI s with very
powerful very powerful with point like
16 gigs of high speed ram or like the
top end I 7c alienware alpha PC or alpha
no I forget whatever their big
triangular piece yes one that looks like
Tutankhamun's buried oh yeah I think
alpha is the steam machine it rigged it
should easily like no problem be able to
run it and I put Ultimate Edition in or
I downloaded it yesterday they download
itself took a long time I don't know how
much that is windows from the windows
and stone yeah there is a known bug with
windows 10 store and it's not just with
gears that when it shows download
progress it shows it like an increment
so you may say like two percent forever
and then jump to like 30 so that anyway
but um yeah and right from the first
cutscene when Marcus is in its jail cell
it was kind of unplayable d cutscene
itself from what I remember and from
what I played today should be like 40
seconds yeah I think it took me three
and a half minutes or she'll get through
it because I would keep just chugging
and the audio itself was kind of doing
the same thing we running it on high
settings or guy tried it on medium I
tried it on high and Trinity yeah yeah
there there is a setting so ambient
occlusion is the thing that simulates
the scattering of light in an
environment and
microsoft adcenter press release late
last night saying like users with AMD
hardware having issues one ready to
rectify that as turn off ambient
occlusion I asked him about Nvidia and
they say we haven't heard any problems
with that but we were screwing around a
little bit and turned off ambient
occlusion this morning even and there
was also an update for the game right
yeah but something some update when I we
had been playing far cry on and so we
the Machine updated something through
Windows 10 and it was running much
better I haven't played on the other rig
lest so I last night at home I was
playing and that was like different set
of problems those were 970 TI's I
believe yeah just one though right air
csrs 970 and uh same problem should
still no different problems uh so it's
running much more smoothly but it was it
was uh essentially screen tearing a lot
of it and I you know I turned on like
turned on and off the anti-aliasing to
make sure wasn't anything specific
describing like pop in yeah there was a
like odd granular offense right that's
yeah there's a pop in a lot of times the
game is so especially when you're doing
those active reloads that the game you
know set the president for every time I
went to do one of those that it would
just the game would stutter really quick
so it's there all eyes and it was weird
it was only then and then also a few
other times when I pause the game the
drivers just stopped working they were
completely updated but I don't know how
much that was I don't know if that was
widespread but right so lots of problems
we don't know if it's been fixed at this
stage it's looking more optimistic but
yeah I'd have to play a little more
about both rigs to kind of see what the
deal is ok so kind of watch this space
at this yeah four thousand dollar pc is
not a good test case for an average pc
route yeah which is what we've been
using on today when it seemed to be a
little bit better so over the next few
days we're gonna keep an eye on it and
see I things improve cool so is there
gonna be a special review going up for
this one than pc version of we've got
that review of my god got it up this
morning will probably be updating it
assuming that performance issues are
fixed if not then it will remain
wonderful one of the get on pc is i had
to drop to a 64 alright in tissues 7 on
xbox one is what you got back in yeah
actually it's coincidental we were
talking about twilight princess you know
a same thing the still a good game just
you know in retrospect a lot of things
have an aged well yeah I
two and three a lot more I have played
them recently and I think they there's a
pretty big leap between one and two but
you know one I was finding its footing
in 2006 and thousand six it was a great
game but i think you know ten years
later just like twilight princess okay
hasn't really aged as well yeah it was
kind of the first of its kind it wasn't
the first cover of a shooter but it was
like the first big corporation raise the
bar for sure raised the bar there you go
yeah where's the roof yeah chin let's go
my bed yeah what a raise idioms do you
have in your pocket uh raised by wolves
hey go raised by Marcos how works I
don't have any don't I don't look at me
may go well if you have any raised by
idioms yourself please by all means put
them in the comment box below and i also
want to talk to you you're not done yet
put that cup of water your mouth young
man he drowned yourself die right here
on the stream and Far Cry primal
reviewed it last week it feels like
we've been playing it I can't believe
it's only been a week since it came out
because it feels like we've had it for
like three weeks but I'm and the pc
version came out today mm-hmm I saw a
bunch of people putting reviews up over
the weekend saying that there was
problems with that technically how was
that one running on PC so far I've only
played about 90 minutes and I haven't
experienced many problems at all um you
know rob was training on like through 4k
and he said it does work but it doesn't
perform very well right which isn't is
not terribly surprising but again the
machine we're using should be able to
handle it yeah but specifically using
sli with that game presented framerate
issues the benchmark would go down to
about 20 frames per second even on 1080
all right using sli but then you kick it
down to one card it was fine uh-huh so I
think it's another example of just you
know the pc market having so many
different variables for developers to
create for and it just takes time to fix
problems as they're reported yeah just
presumably that's why it came out a week
after the console versions well often
that's that's maybe Reese maybe i don't
know i'm very curious why I came out a
week after yeah honestly hmm usually
people are a little bit worried when
that happens I'll be playing more of it
after the lobby just uh you know
hopefully update art or just update our
review with the pc likes having a lot of
fun retreading old ground yes it was
like it
yeah retreading a remaster yeah for 2006
playing far cry again that was I wasn't
trying to joke or just like look at the
vita versions is nostalgia mixed with I
never mind and the other weird thing
about primal actually which I was
noticing when we did the stream I think
it was two weeks ago maybe if we have
any footage from primal actually put it
on because this will be interesting for
people watching on the twitch stream is
that there's this problem that keeps
happening with games which are like
foliage dense that they just don't
stream well at all right because of just
bid race because the way the video
compression is trying to basically like
figure out what elements within the
world are going to move on which
elements are going to move because this
game has such foliage at such distances
as well that when I was playing back the
stream we did last week it looked like
garbage like mud yeah just like awful
muddy nonsense so like any for maybe it
doesn't show some well the nighttime
stuff but like especially in the daytime
would like the light bleeding through
and everything and the folks in the
church i can probably attest it is it
just looks awful and muddied and weird
and this is becoming like a major
problem with game streaming especially
on I feel like on YouTube more so
because they're bit rate is so low and
we had a same problem with hitman
actually two weeks earlier where for
whatever reason it just looks so flat
when it was when you were streaming it
but not locally you're like no locally
look fine but it's just for whatever
reason stuff just wasn't wasn't looking
as good it's almost like because we've
gotten so used to streaming looking like
regular HD 60 frames a second that when
it doesn't it like looks complete like a
game like super hot looks perfect
streamed right cuz it's just missile
high contrast yeah completely yeah so it
all just like works perfectly but yeah
because it was strange last week when we
did the primal scream people work seeing
how it looks like garbage I was like
really he doesn't look that bad then
wash it back and it was yeah did not
look great so it's an interesting new
problem for him especially for PC
players who were like I want to see the
game running on PC like that's how I
used to like buy pc games is I'd go to
gamespot look up gameplay clips and be
like now looks pretty good I'll buy that
but like games has a problem it's weird
there you go thank you so much for your
your frame rate update is yeah well
what's on next week's agenda
even know I've been playing a lot of
devil daggers lately oh gosh yeah I have
you think I would have gotten past like
180 seconds by now but I don't know I
can barely get past like like 70 and I'm
struggling it's tough yeah if there's it
is deceivingly complex game is it it's a
lot deeper than you might think with all
the different things you can you have to
pay attention to and you could do like
this the shotgun jump that helps a lot
oh really yeah I don't know well my
glass on that later are you were vain
yeah I made him review okay more
thoughts on that to come like five bucks
on steam i think it's cheaper than that
might be like re knows those games yeah
God has so many great games coming at
weird little games coming in steam have
you been paying a very I do you guys
late factorial I've heard you and Josh
and go nuts about that got robbed on
board with that too yes Josh and rod
we're gonna do stream after the lobby
and I implore anyone who wants to watch
weird pc games to watch factorial yeah
it looks really complex not that that's
a bad thing I'm chagrin to those games I
have the time to devote to them but it
looks I don't I don't think I know
what's going on yeah it's basically a
game where you land on a planet and then
you were an engineer who if stop me if
you've heard this before you chop down
trees and mine stuff to try and survive
okay but instead of like building up an
outpost and filling it full of nice
things you like you basically end up
he's an engineer so you just build like
robots to mine the coal and robots to
you know conduct energy and turrets to
stop the aliens for trying to kill you
and stuff and then by the end you've
just made this like it's a system of
like conveyor belts and different
elements of like science like energy and
research over here and mining over here
and then you can get them to assemble
stuff so you can just get the machines
to combine the ingredients together to
make things so you'll have this like
really complex conveyor belt system that
just spits out more conveyor belts it's
like it's absolutely mental it's
definitely the right like a Josh Shaw
game yes loving kerbal space program
everything it seems like one of those
ones you have to do some research yeah
just to figure out what you want to do
next and it's killing it on Stan I think
it's got the highest user review score
in the steam history or something which
it's kind of one of these genre games
right we're like you're either in today
yeah oh you're not so if you're into it
then you're probably gonna give it a
high score but yeah it's super good the
guys are going to stream it after the
show so cool stick around i'll watch
that in the meantime though let's uh
let's talk a little bit about the dark
souls the third Dark Souls game yourself
and Mary Mary's currently on the switch
at the moment in a great job hit those
buttons Mary yeah you got a go and you
guys put up a bunch of Rico videos on
gamespot area today gameplay and sort of
features about what's in it and I don't
want to delve too much into the exactly
why you guys talked about there just
give it a quick overview of what you saw
last week at the docks was three event
and why you're excited about sure her
Edmond trend and I Tran and I from our
Australia office we all played the first
three hours roughly we had four hours
but I think once you be the third boss
that's pretty much three hours they
might change a few things when the game
releases in about a month in the US a
little more than a month but it pretty
much we got to see how you're
specifically traveling throughout the
world how you're leveling up how you're
making your weapons better how there's
no more hollowing if you're a Dark Souls
player you know what Paula's you know
you die your health starts gradually
going down until you can you know become
human again now there's like embers and
they pretty much when you die you lose
the flame the cinder something whatever
it's called I'd have to look back at the
article but and that's essentially just
once you beat a boss it rekindles you
and then you your health goes back up or
you can find these embers in the world
so that's going to be one of the major
mechanics the world itself is actually
pretty fragmented each area is pretty
like labyrinth een and it's very still
much a lot to explore and everything
which is exciting because that's you
know those games are never giving you
too much direction yeah but now there
are areas you can't just get to like an
you might in an open world you have to
actually go to the to a bonfire too fast
travel in previous games all right the
bond professional connectives right yeah
they facilitated fast travel now that
they're necessary to travel you still go
back to the Firelink shrine I know a lot
of people didn't love the hub world and
to for them unfortunately it's back same
as blood-borne it's kind of the way they
do in there
I have ya going back to the hunters
dream and then have to go back out and
up into the overworld um yeah overall we
got to pick whatever class we wanted I
went with a warrior just in the interest
of beating the third boss um Mary went
with the sorcerer and add one with the
thief so we got to try out a few
different things we have videos of all
those three bosses are really varying
been you know scale and like how you
fight them first one was just a tutorial
kind of a night with leaping attacks and
a spear and whatnot the next one Voort I
think VOR dt I don't know ye he's more
of a like a four-legged dashing you have
to do a lot of side dish and kind of
stay between his legs yeah sort of like
a weak spots Mary yeah Mary has a
nickname for him but it escapes me right
now but um yeah and then the qurbani
comments gigantic um it's like this
something rotted tree or something and
he he's so angry lasting tree yeah he's
so fat that he can't really attack you
he just falls on you he tries to like
land all his weight on you and there's
specific bulbs on his body or you have
to keep hitting and there it was just
the three bosses I fought we're all
different in their own way and doesn't
have that like amazing feeling when you
meet bosses that it did in Dark Souls 12
though or is this like it's great that
this series become so popular but is it
having that same effect yeah it's still
it's still pretty difficult um I think
the other people the event were having
much more trouble with the third boss
and I was but the second boss one that
took me a while i think mary night that
was our hang up the third when I kill in
the second try but maybe that's because
I was again the Warriors much more
damage so I was kind of you know I had
the advantage there but uh ya know they
I was still exhilarating to kill them
and then you know you get you go back to
Firelink shrine and can you get new
upgrades from killing these bosses and
what Naughton yeah I'm uh I'm excited to
see more I can't really speak to the
quality of obviously the overall game
yet but of those first three or four
hours i played it's very it's looking
promising so we'll see what happens we
see some gameplay here which you guys
recorded what are you playing on what
console that was on xbox one this one
guy we played on pc last year when we
had that preview event right I
it's good actually hear ya so oh yeah it
looks it looks it looks good at the demo
for sure was the pc version looking
noticeably better or was it cuz i
troubled with PC ports in the past well
the pc version i played was back in
august right or so so I I don't know i'm
sure it's made they've made progress
with it since then I remember looking
fine in August was it locked at 30
frames for a second ah that was the deal
with the first few games up musi oh
right uh I don't know I think our I
don't know I think I'd look back at our
videos well we do have a video from
August 2015 they should just hire that
one guy we did all that lighting stuff
on it and so tell me about some of the
new stuff in it done as well I know the
the weapon arts as sure in a today and
it's kind of like leborgne esque where
the weapons kind of have alternate uses
yes or new like currency for this or any
like ammunition almost for this um yeah
so that's what another thing we got to
see they're called FP points okay I'm
not entirely sure what that stands for I
tried lunch figure yeah fruit punch
points it's the blue it's like a mana
bar and the cool thing is you know you
have typical Estus flasks for your
health and then you have like the FP
flasks and when you go to the blacksmith
you can a lot more slots t to one of the
other you have four total slots so you
just say I don't use Matt webinar so I'm
just gonna go for Estus flasks or you if
you're a sorcerer like Mary maybe be one
to consider this because she used the
magic she could just say you know I want
one Estus flask is the last resort but
I'm just gonna go three of the mana
flasks so it kind of is that risk reward
thing or just tailoring to your play
style but yeah you kind of have to just
manage how much how many FP points you
have until the next bonfire until you
kill the next boss because once you're
out you can't use weapon arts hmm and
each that goes play a big part it's dark
souls answer to blood-borne trick
weapons you know you could like extend
the saw blade or turn the put the sword
into the Kirk hammer these ones you
switch essentially to like a two-handed
grip and then you know the battle axe is
like this war cry is a damage buff or
you know you can kind of the long swords
actually have these specific attacks
that might do more damage to a certain
enemies with the nail they take
thrusting damage miss
Slayer image spear and people that yeah
I think that's in assassin no that's a
hell there's a Harold Harold sorry
pitcher Dark Souls yeah terminology
right bro so that's a Harold I've not
played yet we do have yet wait footage
of all the weapon arts as you're seeing
now but yeah it's it it definitely feels
like a Dark Souls game with blood-borne
influence influences but still its own
separate entry which is why I'm
optimistic about it but again what to
see when we get the game don't you had a
month's time or so what we are actually
gonna get the Japanese version so we can
play Turley oh right comes out March
24th in Japan and golden April 12 yeah
everywhere else right so why that's
actually I didn't realize it was that
much of a distance between the two it
yay week after GDC it's probably a good
idea that something we called GDC cool
awesome Mike mohanty thank you so much
and yeah if you're a fan of Dark Souls
do want to see more of that stuff make
sure to go to gamespot com Mike and Mary
put up a bunches of sweet videos go
check a man friends buddy and Mike hey
had multiple friends in what you are you
have that problem that is because i have
four eyes it's peter and then this
painter whenever you go to games could
be linked concise we have one more
segment on this show where we take
something which is in a package Oh take
it out of the package yeah this package
I didn't know about stuff I know we got
a package this morning do you know a
package this is I know what package it
is tell mike well packaging the HTC vive
ohio sorry v.v oh man the ricky martin
viva la vie de vivre a vivre a forever
apparently so we haven't opened we all
I've no idea what's in this we don't
even know where we're gonna set it up
yeah so this is so we're going to just
do it I've been told that this is not
this is it's a vibe but it is not the
final product version because the
packaging is likely change and all that
stuff it's probably the one they've been
giving out to developers recently yeah
so it's probably going to look a little
bit nasty so actually yeah put down here
and i'll pick pick things at one by one
here is the manual closer or none well
man 1 sorry Frank case remember not
final packaging this is for preview
purposes only tonight six you see
official notarized notes dan written
though his Ephraim what's-his-face the
man who never responds I don't know is
that I don't think we wrote that but
there you go I suppose yeah Doug
Lombardi hey guys I snuggling but yeah
dr. Martiros I'm still not convinced
he's a real person stuck he's written to
me email me once Doug church beginning
to be before i was in how many emails
did it take before you get our smoke
okay here we go this is the first part
it's a wall nervous so i can you buy a
TV and like the worst part comes out of
the box first i have to tear this of it
and even if i don't i'm going to post I
call that empty space for video sec you
cushion from the good people of video
sec you a video sec you solutions
speaker wall and ceiling match so there
you go there you go can mount your
ceiling stand up
oh that's actually surprisingly way okay
here's a box it has vibrant no sorry v.v
did you just stick your head in the box
and that's the headset it just pops out
you wish it was that easy okay what we
got what's enough this is probably the
unit right start here yeah as the dev
kit that's yeah it's okay so it is a
deaf kid whoo you want you unbox that
bad boy okie dokie it's actually not as
heavy as I thought it would be whoo put
it on so you can look like one of those
flying things from the matrix that's
right it's a Rises look like one of
those I'm sorry I keep hitting the
microphone ah it's too tight but I don't
care it's so weird with this one count
at the camera in front the cow in the
front makes that look like you've got
this weird Cyclops thing I said that and
this is the breakout box which is an
HDMI USB 3 receiver type thing so they
go yeah you and you just keep that on
for the rest of this we've sort of been
we've sort of like ruined this unboxing
by taking at the only part anyone cares
about but I'm really interested to see
what else is in here and okay here's
some here's some stuff here's a that's a
power supply cable don't cares about
that speak for yourself this is a USB
three breakout cable Waystation TV
what's this looks just like it something
just a weight that you put on no that's
that's its padding for the there you go
put this on figured it out put down
that's padding for the inside of the
thing yeah we're gonna need like 20 of
these because that things gonna get real
grimy in this office plus all right
let's get this so this is the final dude
that's what the inside looks like this
you get in the light a little bit here
this is the future p thing like that
yeah you're watching the future video
games get unboxed right now and then
look at this length that is cable it's
huge it's USB 3 and hdmi yeah cable it
looks like it's about 220 feet maybe you
think sure there you go taking an
estimate better be at least 25
to minister and here's another cable all
right let's see what's in here nothing
we do believe you know when you're uh
cloth wiping all the filth off of here
hi you been to a chiropractor and they
have those the beds you put your face in
two but they've never been known unless
this feels like that nice it's strangely
appealing yeah do we get the little
cameras where the little cameras I think
they're coming down there sorry by the
way this is not playing for the podcast
audience I apologize so much well do our
best to do visual descriptions of all of
this okay this box feels heavy and I
feel like it's probably the the stuff
you want to want to do that one Mike
sure it's a lot more than our big box
news well this is eight hundred dollars
worth of hot equipment for those in the
chat wondering about price alright
what's in that one Mike unpadded here's
aa what they look like hey in Ginza
right what are they called lighthouses
something like that doesn't look like
any light as I've ever seen look like a
dark house nice work nice one ad did I
sit on the floor no so these ghosts in
here on an elevated platform or pedestal
whatever you have so that it can sort of
look down upon the room you might even
mounted to the ceiling with your video
sec you premium wall mount thank you
video sec you oh hello oh yes these are
very I haven't held these yes oh no no
okay this is this is the weirdest thing
dr. thing I've ever but what so I get
here let's get a frown d so I've used
the oculus touch stuff yeah which feels
a little bit weird this is what am i
doing it right here you do you do you've
actually just wanted it I mean all you
do is you do it these are the
controllers just hold him there doesn't
stop at the whole what's the holes of it
uh is this is not an R rated show right
no I think it's virtual reality god it's
there all these little ir emitters okay
I believe on here and these are the the
little lighthouse things are the sensors
that pick up the emitter zand so I
imagine you know I really don't know I
think I could just make up something
that's a total guess aunty social gamer
said set phasers to stun yeah they do
kind of look a little bit so a nice good
night it's a good click 10 out of 10 and
then this is just like the haptic
feedback thing uh oh I wouldn't call it
apps haptic feedback that term gets
thrown around a lot right it's a
touchpad that I think vibrates a little
bit all right gross yeah you're right
its best but we're all gonna some point
no you won't um but ya know these things
uh they work really well I've used it
they have this this grip sensor that I
really like oh is that what that is yeah
okay so that has to do like when you're
grabbing things rather than right
trigger which would work but you don't
really grab things by hooking it with
your index finger grip it with your hand
right and so it definitely gives that
sensation of actively grabbing a thing
wow that's cool and then and then firing
it at somebody because all of the games
are about shooting things while standing
still please did they give us any any
games at this bad boy uh that's a good
question we purchased this or was this
actually supply this was provided to us
by valve thank you thank you very much
valve which probably mention that those
well I think we also are in the we're
gonna preorder one of these bad boys as
well probably uh yeah I mean we need to
get a few of these and the same with it
goes of the oculus rift because there
are a lot of games coming out at launch
and for one person to test all of them
would be insane yeah it's been you for
the past three years for games foz I
think yeah we've Scott Butterworth has
sort of picked up some of that he went
to valve but a month ago yeah thanks to
go do much cool stuff i think i will be
reviewing most of the launch games for
oculus most of the notable ones anyway
let's say turn you just turn it on I
heard a beer this button will never
touch bed sounds like one of those old
LCD game machines this is I I got were
like on a lift set right here and I
literally can't see any light it's like
actually really impressive how could
this
is blocking head all the light the best
sunglasses money can buy you go yeah
can't even see the Sun and yeah sorry I
do we have games to play on this bad boy
then uh I'm sure we will have access I'm
not sure if we have them at this Center
I probably via that URL maybe or
something yep cool well there you go we
just unboxed of VV VV virtual reality
thank you so much am I even near the
microphone I got even gentleman yeah and
before we wrap up today's show thank you
so much to everyone who's been watching
on twitch and everyone who's been
reviewing on iTunes and stitcher and all
of the other wonderful ways in which you
can consume this beautiful piece of
media but before we leave Mike my hearty
what do you walk to on gangs well what's
going on with you redneck rest of the
week I'll be playing more primal on PC
devil daggers and probably just
finishing off twilight princess cool
well I started a stick of truth for the
first time really a few days ago yeah I
did it go down in price recently or
something xiamen of them no I know my
roommate new roommate has it and just
I'd never played in it was just on his
steam so let's play that nice work you
something makes it broke into Tim Tory's
bedroom and played stick truth yeah it
was actually Jake Decker's no was it
yeah oh wow so many new room is sleeping
I like it and feet around what are you
up to on games fun right now is taken
care a bunch of like boring middle
management stuff yeah I know it's a lot
of fun see what no I was good say
something I'm not gonna say in it uh I'm
gearing up to review hitman which is
coming out soon yes and I'm sure
audience will love to know that yeah
come on I've never played a hitman game
oh wow really yeah how are you going to
review this game considering they're
releasing this starter pack situation
which are going to keep adding to its
gonna be very interesting well my friend
you can purchase the first pack which
includes a prologue and some levels for
15 bucks oh of course so therefore it is
actually more simple than it seems yeah
but you would have to bend over
backwards and search all these forums
and stuff to figure out exactly how this
game is being released because yeah
almost every place is selling it just
straight up 60 bucks really but okay
yeah cuz you can get a season pass new
versions you can get the season pass
built into it I can tell ya but really
just by the 59 that's crazy
it's more complicated because they
change this back in January they've
changed it a couple times yeah so I hope
it's good I like to have a debate I know
what I hope every single video game is
good me too honest video games I hope
virtual reality is good because
otherwise this is one hell of a piece of
buyer's remorse let's go get this thing
set up yeah ASAP yeah so for me I'll
have an episode of the point later this
week which very which may very well be
the final episode of the point it'll
definitely be the final episode of the
point no with our main man here mr.
Andrew branwen who is behind the car
there you go there's the back of his
beautiful had it don't even worry no
one's even looking at that Andy's were
working at gamespot for how long now for
for foreign change for one half years or
something and we're very very sad to see
him go he's going on to greater things
Andy's been a conjugated to this website
for all that time worked alongside
everyone here at gamespot as was coming
funny giant bomb 30 years he has been
instrumental in all of the shows i put
together pretty much here on gamespot
and i know i will personally very miss
miss him very much i know everyone here
at came following miss him a lot as well
so thank you so much to mr. andrew brown
skin thank you Andy it's popular in the
control room as well yeah so I hit him
up and about Andy Berman on Twitter I
think it is yeah and send him your best
wishes we will have an episode of the
point later this week and we'll be back
of course next Tuesday 2 p.m. pacific
right here in the lobby thank you so
much to everyone who put together this
show and Mary Kish on the Wheels of
Steel spinning those buttons here look
hit those buns amazing perfect great
always place with the podcast Josh Shaw
on the back as well for helping said
Richard and mr. damn horik will be back
next Tuesday 2pm Civic stick around
factorial stream coming up right now
stay there see in a minute